are they still doing pcr tests yes and
so this is like your expertise you're
saying these pcr tests are not accurate
not as accurate well it's not that
they're not as accurate they they get
trace artifacts and they basically do a
polymerase
chain reaction where they actually
recreate the coveted particle using and
using the other strand to the base
pairing on that rna so they can tell if
you've had covet or if you your body's
reacting you've got the antibodies but
they don't know if you're actually able
to transmit or not so they can't tell
viral loads so you could be asymptomatic
with a very limited load and they they
can't see that so they need different
tests yeah and i think it's really
obvious that they went to this direction
of even if you're vaccinated you gotta
get tested because i said this couple
weeks ago
how does it make sense that you're gonna
be like
you can't come to the movies unless
you're vaccinated or get weakly tested
and i'm like breakthrough cases exist
and people who have breakthrough cases
can transmit to the same degree as
someone with like who's not vaccinated
once you get once once you get coven
your chance of transmission is like
equal regardless of vaccination status
but those who are vaccinated are much
less likely to get that's what they're
saying but if that's still the case they
can transmit then doesn't everyone need
to test
but they were like nah and i was like
okay now here we are university of
arizona is the first to be like yeah
everybody get your tests so do you know
so now that this delta variant is out
are they still vaccinating for the
original variant even though there's a
new variant that's traveling so when
people are getting sick with covid are
they actually put in quotes are they
getting sick with a variant that the
vaccine is not prepared for there's all
sorts of different variants of you know
covid and the difference is that you can
have a variant of covet that literally
does absolutely nothing like if you go
ahead and you look at the sequencing
data on giza you'll see
so many different like on gized where
they share the actual data from the pcr
tests and from like people that they
actually confirm positives they can tell
you what prevalence that specific strain
is they've got a bunch of them and it's
a bunch of different areas just sharing
that data so
you have variants that do absolutely not
you know nothing over the actual version
that's natural because the rna virus
you're going to get you know single
nucleotide polymorphisms where again a
code you know one of the base pairing
skips or one of the base pairings omits
and it's not the right one and so
the question is
what does the delta variant do do we
even know because a lot of people say
that it's more transmissible but you got
to think the delta variants started
coming around right as everybody started
getting coveted apathy
you know lockdowns were being released
in a lot of places they're brushing in
it's like how do you gauge
transmissibility
if you're not infecting somebody
recovered telling them to walk the same
distance around the same amount of
people not touch anybody but get within
this distance you can't control
to see how transmissible a specific
strain is so do we know that it has any
and this is the hot button demonstrated
gain of function
over normal you know over the normal
star cov2 string
like that's the question that you have
to actually ask nobody like when someone
walks in if if something were to happen
we're like
this person got covered from that person
they i've never i i've been following
this for a while and i don't know they
don't say what strain they caught so i
keep thinking it's the original
but
it might not be right well so so here's
what i think happened and you know
consult your doctor cause i'm not an
expert on this but i was reading about
it and basically when we had the alpha
strain
it was like the original strain it was
it was it was brutal
it was more deadly less infectious but
what happens is natural selection occurs
right so the virus that cause the
viruses that cause outside of cova just
in general virus and you can probably
correct me if i'm wrong on this one but
viruses that cause more damage are less
likely to spread because the person
notices it and then takes action so
viruses that are less deadly and less
you know causing of symptoms are more
likely to transmit
naturally selecting for a highly
transmissible but less deadly variant
yeah so what happens is i here's what i
think this is my opinion
the alpha variant i think was
nightmarish like the data we were
getting the videos we were seeing it was
horrifying we saw videos of people
collapsing in the street in china people
are now saying they're fake no i don't
think that's what's happening i think
what happened was the initial strain was
people are saying there's like a
pressure on their chest and so you've
got people in china who are like
pressured to go out work and and you
know they have there's like a more honor
culture so it's like put a mask on and
get out there and then someone would be
struggling to breathe
and what happens when you can't breathe
you pass out yeah they're bad air there
too anyway right so you got bad air
you've got pressure on the chest and
this weird like pneumonia was going
around so we see this data and the
initial origin the initial data was like
we could see millions die from this in
the u.s like the new york times had a
slider bar models
but what happens is there's a natural
natural selection that occurs the most
severe strains are eliminating
themselves by killing people the less
severe variants were more likely to
transmit because the people were less
likely to be hospitalized so then we
went alpha we had beta you know now
we're we've seen epsilon and mu but
delta seems to be the scarier one it's
highly transmissible and still deadly
but less deadly this really makes sense
so now
we're getting to that point perhaps
where you know people are saying we have
to live with covid
but this the worst strain of cova will
probably fizzle itself out so i'll throw
it back to the 1918 flu pandemic for
another point of data
there's a uh one one historical theory
that the 1918 pandemic started in china
as a very uh as a lighter string
and a bunch of people got it and they
got over it but then it moved into the
trenches came back to the united states
where it festered and got worse and
because it had the ability to rapidly
infect close-quartered people who were
injured or sick
that allowed for a very serious variant
to rapidly infect lots of people
by the time it made it back to china
the people of china already had some
natural immunity to to a similar strain
and were less impacted by it
in this instance it's it's similar but
different
the very serious strain was struggling
because we did the slowdown we did the
lockdowns we did these things i think
it's fair to say we probably had a
positive impact in that regard but then
variants can still persist and we made a
lot of mistakes notably
being indoors seems to be bad
being outside with fresh air with uv
lights with vitamin d with exercise
seems to be good so we made some
mistakes in the capacity we need to
update our strategy now i think we're in
a new pandemic a pandemic of political
manipulation where we do have a crisis
chronovirus is really bad we're still
hearing stories about people getting it
but now you've got political parties
that are like now's our chance never let
a good crisis go to waste exactly and i
mean they're doing that and you know
part of the issue as well though you can
actually argue with lockdowns is that
you allow and incentivize mutations when
you lock down because when they finally
get out or when they have to actually go
out and they've been locked down for so
long they're spreading a much more
mutated iteration it went through about
five or six viral viral generations and
now you're getting something that
there's always a small chance that when
a virus mutates that it can demonstrate
a little bit more virulence and it can
become a lot more deadly but that's
interesting locking down essentially
created isolated incubation
is are viruses more or less likely to
mutate in isolation
it isola pretty much if we never lock
down what would happen is that everybody
kovit would burn through his host
reservoir eventually we would reach hurt
immunity a lot faster that's at least
you know that's the traditional logic i
think it still stands there's a lot of
inconsistency on it and i'm not going to
give you a definitive but what happens
is you let it burn through its host
reservoir and again people are going to
you know people are going to succumb to
the illness that's part of the nature of
it but
once it actually burns through
everybody's already immune you know
they're immunized so you don't have a
let's say a generation one covid and
then generation five you know a
generation five
encoded illness going in generation five
is so much different from generation one
that eventually you get a chance
mutation that allows it to spread a
little bit easier a question if you
don't know the answer it's okay if if uh
if you become immune to like alpha of
covet alpha it can it mutate in your
system once you develop immunity to the
alpha can it
that that's always a possibility that's
actually something that you know we take
well okay
it's complicated because once you have
the antibodies once you have the
immunoglobulin g antibodies within your
blood once it's there
again it's going to eventually get wiped
it's going to eventually get wiped out
and then the rest of your antibody
production will catch on lymphocytes and
the dendritic cells will begin to
dispose of it so you will eventually get
rid of the infection entirely
but the issue is again
what it you know
how do you control for whatever you're
spreading because you have a thousand
different variants of the virus here and
once that's the most transmissible will
then be able to be shed to somebody else
and then that one will actually spread
and it'll copy those transmits you know
it'll actually carry those same
transmissibility traits and it might
actually improve on that further and
further and further and then they might
actually spread that one but you know
it's all chance it's like you know
you're rolling a dice every single time
because first you have to actually
spread the most transmissible variant of
invariant of it and then you have to
hope that that one doesn't
self-terminate or snuff itself out every
single time that it's hijacking a cell
and getting itself to be reproduced
if it snubs itself out or if you don't
actually spread it and your body
actually develops immunity to it
you know that's that's game over so it's
basically a chance thing that's why i
say mutations are they're drummed up to
such a degree that you know it's like
tim said they're they're not letting a
good crisis go to waste but really this
is something mundane that we're making
sound so exotic i think i think
initially
i actually do think the initial like
everything we saw initially was accurate
and we have to we have to make sure
we're updating the science as as the
mutations happen and assess our economic
circumstances it started with a novel
virus that it was highly infectious and
it was novel so it's likely going to hit
everybody
and it was just uh uh as they reported
not a lab leak but just very
interestingly it had these proper you
know infection methods but in the
beginning they're like look nobody's had
this so that means everyone's gonna get
it there's no natural immunity to this
and that means we're gonna see a lot of
death and so we wanted to do something
about it i think that was legitimate but
what happens is
with mutations with bad policy we're not
perfect we make mistakes we should have
done different things i can accept that
trump should have fired fouchy i
definitely think that is fauci has got
no confidence in the american people
but it's hard to say we're at a point
now where i'm wondering if the hard
lockdowns allowed for isolated
incubation so put it this way
if the population is rapidly
intermingling then there will be
variance but people will quickly catch
certain strains and then develop
immunity to those strains granted with
the novel virus we're talking about a
lot of deaths so it's a scary sentence
you know it's it's scary to just be
we're going to ignore this well then you
get overloaded hospitals
but if you tell everyone to lock down
then what happens is let's let's say you
have 10 buildings that are sealed
each with their in each are infected
with kovid
when they open the doors you could you
could have 10 variants because they went
through multiple like you said five or
six generations now it comes out with 10
different strains all at once
so
look i'm not going to pretend to be an
expert on this or an actual policy
somebody is at this point right right
it's hard to know for sure the one thing
i can say is when you look at australia
you look at what's happening with
democrats i think they're like it's an
opportunity for us to push through
agenda items to to you know do a lot of
things now interestingly i guess you
know gretchen whitmer like his opposing
vacs mandates and and mask mandates
polling or polling was bad or something
like that she missed out on numbers all
right she's
for the people well i i'm glad that's
the case but i don't think it's going to
save her career i think too many
democrats saw this as an opportunity
they started by saying come on down to
chinatown that's what nancy pelosi was
saying remember that nancy pelosi not
wearing a mask getting her hair done
gavin newsom not wearing a mask one of
these restaurants they don't care about
this and i'll tell you this
celebrities aren't scared of this at all
no take into consideration that they go
to the enemies they'll go to the mat
golly they don't wear masks they don't
care they literally do not fear this at
all so if you're sitting at home and
you're worried and you're scared about
this ask yourself why it is that
political elites and celebrities have
zero fear they go on tv they don't wear
masks they go to special events they
don't wear masks they do not care about
this
there's the infam there's just such an
informational lag because i think
conservatives are on the cutting edge of
this conservatives have already gotten
to the point where we've accepted that
this is going to be an endemic virus
it's not as bad as it could be practice
good health get outside again because
you need the vitamin d and also because
heat stimulates interferons which can
help again
help your body actually ward off the
virus a lot of people don't do research
into interferons children also have a
much higher
number of interferons within their nodes
and that's part of the reason why
children are less susceptible in general
wow but um you know there's so many
there's so many facets to this that the
average person does not know and there's
an information light because they're
getting it from these traditional
sources so what do you do
you make more interferons baby hey yeah
so you're saying it's
endemic which means what does that mean
exactly that means that you're going to
it's basically a part of society you're
going to have a covet every single year
and ask yourself how long have we had a
flu vaccine
oh we've got a bunch of different ones
okay have we gotten rid of the flu yet
okay so why are we trying to do the same
thing with kobe right but i always call
it the flu shot is that because it i
thought it wasn't a vaccine well it's a
it's a more traditional one the mrna
vaccine is where you're exposing
yourself to two specific spiked proteins
out of the 26 that are on the surface of
the sarcov2 virus but these have what's
called a pre pre-fusion conformation
which keeps spike protein from damaging
the cell
basically as it's uh you know as it's
manufactured and it actually locks it
onto your cell in the plasma membrane of
itself so it can't get losing and go and
damage other cells this is the rna one
yeah that's rna it helps your body
basically produce the spike protein so
that you can create those igg or igg
jesus christ
antibodies that's that's the worst
naming convention i'm so glad you're
here
it's complicated it's super it's super
complicated but it's also niche too
because again a lot of urologists
they'll study this and they won't put
two and two together and then you know
you have some virologists that dedicate
themselves to studying interferons you
have some that dedicate themselves to
say studying different methods to deploy
you know
vaccines that's
pretty much how we have the
80 26 in the jansen and that's how we
have the
nanoparticle the lipid covered
nanoparticle of basically the pfizer one
and so uh what's what's a traditional
vaccine called does it have a name
i would say a a live
well no it wouldn't be the live team
right yeah that's pretty much it where
you're presenting an inert copy
so the uh nova vax i think
that's one that's a traditional vaccine
is that a live attenuated or
oh i might actually have to go look at
that the specifics of which i'm i'm
super do you know anything about the
johnson johnson vaccine yes it's it's
it's a dna virus it's a dna vaccine
right i think it still aren't i thought
it was still rna but it was just
deployed using a adenovirus that was
actually found in research monkeys i
could be wrong but i thought that it was
still that we're still dealing with rna
hey kind of as a more general question
are do you think that there's a lot of
promise in the rna vaccines in general i
i mean it's a it's a useful way to do
what we've always done but you know the
weakness of rna vaccines is again it's
blood-borne immunity which means if you
have something that transmits or sheds
via the nodes you're still able to
transmit because that's a different
antibody that you're trying to produce
so it works on blood but not in mucus
not in the lymph nodes yeah those would
be the iga antibodies that you that you
find there your saliva and i believe in
your stomach
it says dna it says that johnson johnson
uses an adenovirus to deliver the spike
protein dna
but
and it's nebraska medicine so i'm
assuming that i i read this too i think
i was writing on the cdc that's a dna
vaccine versus the mrna vaccine similar
but different technologies yeah it's
just the it's the same process just kind
of in reverse dna you're basically
cleaving it into an r you're basically
splitting it into an rna and then giving
it out to your ribosome so that they can
actually you know send it so they can
actually manufacture where it's rna
again it's already ready to go
word it's like inserting a disk into it
it's like inserting a disc with a
program into a computer so before we
move on cd-rom yeah indeed yes before we
move on i have to ask a lot of times
people will just dismiss out of hand the
concept of a vaccine all together
because they'll tell me it's not a
vaccine it's gene therapy what do you
say to that
i mean it's a semantic argument because
you know everything is you know
everything to some degree
are genes like now what i think when
people say gene therapy they're thinking
kind of like a retrovirus where it
actually overwrites the dna of your
cells and causes them to basically
by default produces like i said it's
like just inserting a cd into a computer
and telling it run specific program it's
going to conduct though i was i was
reading a harvard article about gene
therapy a lot of people were sending
saying see it proves mrnas gene therapy
it actually doesn't the harvard article
says that there is mrna gene therapy
mrna vaccines are not gene therapy so
the idea is
basically what they're saying if you've
got a genetic disorder
they can use mrna to literally do a gene
therapy and change the dna in your cells
to stop the disorder
but these vaccines don't do that right
they just give the rna to make a spike
protein and then eventually cease to
exist they allow the ribosomes to
basically go to work and you know again
mobilize the aminos to conduct the
protein and it's only two out of the uh
26 that we you know you you'll find on
the surface too so it's not even like
it's covering the whole cell with it and
i just think
there's a lot of other arguments people
make they use semantic arguments like
gene therapy i'm like what does that
mean like i mean does that affect the
polit the politics of freedom and
medical choice and bodily autonomy
you know right the mandates not the
vaccines because again the vaccines are
you know vaccines are
pretty much wonderful anywhere you
actually been yes these may have you
know you might have a lot of allergic
reactions there's a lot that we don't
know how people's bodies are reacting to
it but you know people react
all medicine has risk yeah people react
oddly to all kinds of medicine medicines
and depending
i'll put it this way if someone comes to
me and says that they would like to go
to vaccine i'll be like that's that's
cool you talk to your doctor and they'll
be like yeah but that's fantastic i'm
glad you did that thank you that's
awesome i don't think we should force
people to do it though and there's
there's arguments about like well what
about all the other vaccines and i'm
like truth be told i still have issues
with government mandated medication i
think people you know but there's
limited function right if you want to go
to a public institution like a school
and they mandate it that's different
from saying all public accommodation
period for participation in society
furthermore the older vaccines have been
around for a much longer time and went
through a legislative process for
approval
it's very different from like we're in a
crisis and we're going to just executive
decree this stuff
so i think it's like um you know the
supreme court said about the eviction
moratorium it's an issue for congress
laws have to be voted on in past and the
problem is when democrats realize they
can't get it through because of
republicans they just say you know we'll
squeeze it in with a budget bill we'll
do the omnibus spending where we just
get whatever we want or biden will rule
by decree yeah and that goes back to
what we said though that again the dem
the democratic party is sick and when
you have a sick party that can't get the
other wing to agree or work with it then
what you get you get these schemes these
plans these ways that you are trying to
control manipulate and snuff out the
other party and that eventually destroys
the nation because you need the ideas of
the left which left does not it doesn't
mean de facto communism let's go go to
that you know left and right or just
semantic terms that we use to describe
traditionalism which would normally be
right
and then you know this whole moving
forward changing things which is what we
see left like if america was
historically a communist country the
commies would be the right yeah and you
know the left would be the capitalists
and could you imagine could you imagine
that uh a group of wall street bets uh
capitalists hurling malls off cocktails
into worker camps yeah but they also
don't like
it's not about being establishment it's
just certain political factions don't
engage in that kind of behavior yeah
whether the revolution or not but let me
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
irl monday through friday at 8pm where
you can leave comments and super chat
and we actually will read your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you